it makes it makes these videos worse
doesn't it it's just 25 000 views like
oh that's not even bad hey they're
American people so it's worth more
that's a Chinese apartment building we
have like Costa Rica views
[Music]
are everybody familiar with those like
Chinese food bloggers that eat [__]
wild stuff and [__] they like
dick-shaped seafood the clam stuff yeah
yeah we must have [__] up one of this
chick with a live octopus is like the a
dog-sized live octopus and she's like
dog dogs range in a lot of sizes like
like a big dog you know what he's
talking about why you gotta be all
difficult
oh like your cat
why you got to do that you know because
your cat's big so think about it like
this it's like your cat on a table and
she's like trying to eat it that was
like how it was isn't that just combined
yeah you got big cats you do have beer
cast hat you do have beer customer so
there's this food blogger back in April
of 2022 who uh
bought this shark on Alibaba what you
could buy sharks on Alibaba live sharks
that would have been your future bought
a great white shark what can't you buy
on what came on on uh on Alibaba Owens
shopping site taobao for 7 700 Yuan
which is 1 141 Is it alive so that means
they'll deliver it to you like straight
up it's let me show you this photo how
many ounces what's the cut that's not a
great white shark this is a great
lifestyle it's just not it's just not a
great great size I can't even see what
she's doing that's a great value shark
is that dead yes it's out of the water
and she's laying next to it this [__]
is like [__] four foot tall that's a
great white shark are you kidding me
there's two meters well a great why it's
supposed to be like a school bus well
yeah they're they're babies first
they're babies first is all so a baby
great white shark that's a baby great
white shark it looks more like a mako
shark dude okay dude
I watch Shark Week one time for a whole
week and I pretty much know everything
about her yeah it's weak yeah it's a
good it's a good week it's a dense week
authorities say that this chick gin had
bought the shark uh in April 2022 and
posted a video on social media platform
do Yin the Chinese version of tick tock
and the video is quickly went viral
showing cooking the two meter long great
white shark in a spicy broth and eating
its meat and in the video she says it
may look vicious but its meat is truly
very tender before taking a bite of the
shark's carcass what's so vicious about
it it's just making it into a culinary
thing
what's vicious about eating a shark yeah
cause vicious
Ozzy Osbourne I'm biting the head off
yeah but when you're cooking it's
civilized yeah exactly I'm like what's
no I think you're being defensive yeah I
think I think just the idea of
purchasing a great white shark species
and then cooking it and eating is all
yeah but uh obviously a lot of people
got very very well it's like why are
they trying to take my gun can you say
bite the carcass she didn't like fillet
it she just cooked the whole thing and
just took a bite like a cartoon I need
to see if there are better photos of
this because that'd be so funny if she
just cut a square from the shark pulled
it out and put it in a suit so read a
random squid looks like this here it's
just a square Block it's like an 8-bit
bite
it looks like this by the time she's
done with it whoa that's like a shark
Steakhouse got it seasoned
is that the fin like the you know you
know every time we do this can still
takes the photo and it edits it on now
and then I didn't know that you're lucky
you should subscribe or something I'll
check it out check it out send me the
link yeah right what kind of it looks
like she has leaking powder or barbecue
powder or something that thing is like
oh like a dry rub or something yeah are
you guys are you guys offended at the
idea of taking this you know particular
species and buying it is it illegal is
it endangered or protected I think it's
I think it's illegal in America oh
that's why we don't do shark fin soup or
something yeah if it's illegal and
that's [__] up what's the point if
you're gonna cover it in Old Bay anyway
[Laughter]
what the [__] is the point you know why
I feel like she isn't as hardcore is
because we saw all those videos of them
eating live [__] all those like Chinese
like food bloggers that are eating like
big cat-sized octopus yeah it was a lot
it was a lot and she's like pouring
Tabasco on it and [__] yeah it's like
wiggling yeah
I think it comes down to the logistics
of how she acquired the shark she can't
get it on Alibaba when when authorities
first began investigating Jin in August
of last year she claimed that she had
bought the great white shark uh legally
and told told them these people are
talking nonsense she had claimed in the
video that shark was bred in captivity
and was edible but an editorial uh said
that uh there were inconsistencies with
her claims and stuff like that it cannot
be excluded that there is a Black Market
um after all to ship a big shark from
the coastal region to Nanchang it
requires coordination
Alibaba is not ethically she was lying
when she said she got on taobao uh I
think apparently there were just
inconsistencies with her claims of where
she was receiving you're buying a
[__] 4 foot shark I mean you could
just search it on taobao and see if
she's lying she should go to jail for
just buying it on Alibaba too these
people are so DJ I can't believe it it's
impressive it's like how much farther
can you go with your content do you
really need to [__] eat a whole giant
she does have like 7.8 million followers
for just eating random sheets like an
ostrich oh those are China numbers those
aren't China numbers that's inflated
exactly it's inflated yeah that's like
that's what the currency that's like
saying oh I have a I have a million you
on but yeah when people say that it's so
funny I was I was working in China on
one of those TV shows and this group uh
called now United they're like this uh
really popular singing group made of
different people from different
countries they did their first show in
China there and this one dude was so
excited he was like oh man it got this
many million views in the first day and
then one of the Gaffers I was with was
like yeah but that's China numbers
that's nothing that kid was like oh
I was like bro
I know a guy I know a guy I used to do
videos with
um he's a nice guy and everything but he
end up um getting paid by the Chinese
government to like go over there and
like make [__] Tick-Tock vids and
[__] and he like blew up over their own
stuff and he was already pretty big over
here but then he goes over there and
like blows the [__] up and then one day
he's like he's like video calling me and
he's like tell me about how he's bigger
than Bieber in China
yeah and I'm like dude if you're bigger
than Bieber you know Bieber doesn't walk
around saying how big he is you just
[__] dark Beaver yeah you gotta tell
everybody he's also never said that I'm
like a beaver by bigger and he starts
blocking everybody on his phone because
he's so big that's like but that's like
when you're with you're with your girl
and you're like like my girl says dick
Size Doesn't Matter actually
that's such a funny thing when people
compare like that weird that's what they
said in China with this one girl they
were like she's the Kim Kardashian of
China and we were like I guarantee Kim
doesn't say she's the you of America
so it's probably not transitive dude we
need that gaffer everywhere bro yeah
we're gonna be so mean China really is a
different planet though you know
its own [__] was he American yeah
yeah he's a buddy of ours he flew out
there he wasn't being a dick he was
being like like sincere because it's a
different Dynamic so it made it worse it
makes it makes these videos worse
doesn't it it's just 25 000 views like
oh that's not even bad hey they're
American piece so it's worth more that's
a Chinese apartment building we have
like Costa Rica views
we have U.S Virgin Islands views dude
we're like viral that's 25 000 it's
viral in like Madagascar okay doesn't
feel very viral out here no it does not
it does not well investigate
investigators identified the shark in
their video as a great white by DNA
testing the leftover tissues in the city
Supermarket area and uh she ended up
getting fined uh 18 500.
no way yeah I'm not mad because it's
illegal there yeah some aspect of it's
illegal like the acquiring of it or like
the it's it's only illegal because she
put it out so largely and they're like
now we gotta step in God damn it eating
it is legal that's always good yeah
and then they eat shark out there so I
was wondering like if it's illegal
worldwide like it's like a poaching
thing it might be different if you're
like you're just eating shark fin soup
that you like got versus like you're
doing viral videos ASMR of like and it's
like live or not live but it's like
whole in one sense and then you have to
like cut it up and cook it but also
though too you said they did a DNA test
to make sure it was great we had some
leftovers yeah so you for sure can't
probably eat great rice sure yeah you
probably cannot you probably can't good
idea tonight maybe a Mako maybe the
fastest though you're gonna have a tough
time you can get shark fin soup here
like if you ate it at a Vietnamese
wedding like you can find it but if you
sell it at a store you can't
but they do like imitation shark fin
soup yeah kind of like olive oil how
it's like now people don't know the
difference because they've been eating
the fake [__] so long so basically
there's a 99 Ranch out there where like
you're walking through and there's an
aquariums like with with a great white
shark in it just
and there's like [__] nine of them
all like on top of each other
and thousands that's the funny part is
she was like farm raised ethically
farm-raised great white shark I didn't
know that you could even farm right now
what kind of tank is that I didn't even
know you could read it for captivity I
didn't know you could do that
successfully I thought that that hasn't
been successful maybe that's why I was
only two two meters yeah it was the
other side it almost fooled the cops it
did look like a [__] up [__] great
white though like it was dead yeah but
it looked [__] up it was on land and
she was lying next to her for a photo
like it didn't reach its potential the
dorsal was way off it doesn't look like
a great way yeah well it doesn't look
like the big scary ones yeah if I if I
saw the if I saw that [__] run up on me
on a boat I just take a baseball but I'm
like get the [__] out of here
with a chain and chains wearing [__]
jeans
sunglasses too yeah with some attitudes
foreign
[Music]